We're headed to the hotel that we're staying at for the conference
Scott: Very late!
Mayuko: Hehe that's okay
We're on our way!
Day 1!
Day Uno!
It's gonna start
Good morning
Today is my talk. It is the morning of my talk. We just got ready. We're about to head to the venue
I just I ran through my talk once earlier and I feel pretty good about it.
Even though I completely missed an entire part
but that's okay because I won't do that again
My talk isn't until like 5:30, it's not for a while. So I'm probably gonna be this little tiny ball of anxiety
Scott: I'm hungry
Yeah I'm hungry too let's go eat
Yeeaaaaaaah talk dayyyy!
Got mah badge!
Scott, are you nervous about me giving a talk? Why?
Scott: mmm, because...
Because why?
Scott: What was the question?
Are you nervous about me giving a talk?
Scott: Yes
Do you think I'm gonna do a good job?
Scott: Sorry, what was the question?
Get outa here!
There's one hour until my talk and I'm so nervous!
I'm so nervous!
I'm just reading through my slides
One last time
I'm so nervous!
There's one hour until my talk and I think I'm going to explode and die either now or on stage
Power pose!
Scott power pose with me!
Announcer: Everyone, Mayuko Inoue!
Hello everybody
Thank you so much for coming to my talk, my name is Mayuko Inoue
みなさん、こんにちは
井上まゆこと申します
[Japanese] Let's take this great energy and connect with the next generation
Thank you very much!
i'm so thirsty
Scott: what's going on?
It's over!
Scott: I mean there's workshops tomorrow
There's workshops tomorrow but I'm done